-Our first guest
is an Emmy-winning
and Oscar-nominated actress
who stars in the new series
"Nine Perfect Strangers,"
which premieres this Wednesday
on Hulu.
Please welcome Melissa McCarthy!
Welcome back. Now...
Thank you so much
for being here, bud.
And thanks for playing
that game.
Is it odd to hear
that's the future?
Like, did you just have to do
syllables when you did that?
-I did both.
It was an immense amount of
recording where you would
just say strange parts of words,
sometimes letters,
sometimes whole paragraphs
that were, like, medical,
and, like, a list of Norwegian
names, and I'm like,
"How often is this
gonna come up?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-And it would just be
the most bizarre --
like, it was, like,
a little bit of everything.
-Did those trip you out?
-And you had to say it
without stopping, so we would do
like 1,500 chunks
of dialogue a day.
It was fun and,
like, completely different.
I've never done
anything like it.
-Last time you were here --
thank you for being on --
you Zoomed --
you were Zooming from Australia.
And, now, you're back home,
which is great.
-It's so nice to be back.
Like, I loved Australia,
but, you know, it's nice.
We were there at a great time,
and I think we've come home
at a good time, hopefully.
-Yeah. You and your husband,
Ben Falcone,
who's very talented, you do this
very fun thing together.
It's called Beer O'Clock.
-Sure.
-Yeah.
-I think we all --
Don't we all do Beer O'Clock?
-I think we all do Beer O'Clock.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But it just kind of
came out of, I guess,
the quarantining,
I guess, right?
And it's, like, kind of saying
it's the end of the day, or...?
-It was just all --
like, he's so --
Ben is so wonderfully weird
and, like,
he'll just make videos
sometimes,
and I have no idea he's doing
it, and then it just shows up.
And he started doing this
weird thing where he was doing
Beer O'Clock, and then, like,
started doing it together.
And we were in -- just to make
it weirder, the last one we did,
where I believe we're in wigs.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-We do a movie group.
We were dressed up as
two of the guys from "Argo,"
which is why we're in wigs
and, like, '70s clothes.
'Cause we dress up as people
from the movies.
And then it was Beer O'Clock,
so we just combined them.
It literally is like,
"How dumb can it be?"
And then he goes,
"We should post this."
Like, it's -- There is no use
to the world.
There's no information given.
But we will dance in our kitchen
with beer.
-And it just made me laugh. It
made millions of people laugh.
I want to show -- here's
Beer O'Clock incorporating wigs.
Take a look at this --
Melissa and Ben.
♪♪
-What's in the can?
-Aaah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-It's so stupid.
It's dumber than I remember.
[ Laughter ]
-How many wigs do you own?
-Ooh. Oh, God.
It's somewhere in the 60s.
Like, I have --
I mean, they're always with me.
There's -- I mean, there's,
like, if you need an Amadeus.
-Oh, that's a good one.
-If you're feeling like
an Orphan Annie.
-Oh, Annie's a great costume.
-And also,
I've gotten into some of these,
which -- pretty --
pretty terrifying for the kids.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that Boris Johnson?
Who is that?
[ Laughter ]
-It is now.
It's his actual skin.
Like, just, you know,
they really change you.
A short-cropped man's wig
really bothers Ben.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-I put this one on backwards,
and it gives me
a little bit of a darker edge,
and it really troubles him.
[ Laughter ]
-Actually, in real life, you are
as much fun as you'd think.
-[ Laughs ]
-And you are, also, I would say,
probably one of the best friends
out there.
And I'm saying this
because I saw something
recently that was posted.
Mariska Hargitay is a friend of
yours, and she broke her ankle.
And you could've -- you texted.
You probably did.
You sent her flowers, whatever
a friend would do and say,
"Hey, get well."
Instead, you took it
to another level.
Can you tell our audience
what you did?
-Well, yeah, she, like, rolled
her ankle, and it was, like,
a really --
a really severe break.
And she's a really good texter,
and I'm terrible.
Sometimes, like, I don't --
like, I put my phone
in my purse for three days,
and then people are like,
"Where are you?"
And she sent me
a really funny text of like,
"Oh, don't worry, I'm just here
in a lot of pain, recovering.
I guess you're too busy
to respond to my texts."
And so I was like,
"Okay, game on."
So, now, I have to make it
seem like "this is why
I didn't get back to you, 'cause
I was petitioning for prayers."
And so we literally jumped
in the car and ran over,
as you do in Burbank,
to Wienerschnitzel.
-Yeah.
-And I just jumped up and down,
and cars honked, and I think
they were like, "What?"
-I wanted to show
a little video.
Here's Melissa McCarthy
out there
supporting her friend
Mariska Hargitay.
[ Laughs ]
So fun.
[ Horn honks ]
There, you got a honk!
That's what I'm talking about
You got a couple --
you got a honk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't tell
if they were thinking like,
"Get well, Mariska,"
or if they were like,
"Get out of the way!"
-Yeah.
No, they loved it. I loved it.
I want to talk about
"Nine Perfect Strangers."
This is what you were filming
in Australia, correct?
-Yeah.
-It premieres this Wednesday.
-It's really a great --
It was such a great book,
and I loved it.
And then when Nicole Kidman
calls and is like,
"Do you want to --
Do you want to do something?"
I basically was like, "I don't
care what it is," or, you know,
if I'm on or off screen,
"yes" was my first answer.
And then it ended up being --
we weren't supposed to do it
in Australia, and it just seems,
like, now, I can't imagine it
not being done there.
The scenery is, like,
the whole -- the whole group,
everybody that came together
to do it was --
It was so fun and especially
during such weird times,
where we'd all been so isolated,
to suddenly have this little
group of, you know,
12, 13 actors and a casting crew
kind of bubble together was --
it was really fun, and it's --
like, I'll never forget it.
-Amazing cast.
Regina Hall, Bobby Cannavale,
Michael Shannon.
-Michael Shannon, yeah.
-Michael Shannon's so funny,
and he doesn't get to be
that funny in these movies.
And every time he does,
he shines.
Watch Michael Shannon. So good.
-He's so funny.
Like, I don't -- Yeah, I think
most people don't get that
he is, like --
as good of an actor as he is --
like, he's such a great actor,
but also he's so weirdly funny.
And it's the same with Bobby.
Like, he always plays,
like, this tough guy.
Bobby is, like, the weirdest,
funniest guy in the world.
Regina's really funny, so it's
this weird mix of, you know,
this odd group of kind of
damaged people shows up,
and, you know, have very strange
tactics for getting better,
many of which they don't
even know about yet.
But it was such a blast to do.
Like, even, you know, some of
the scenes are pretty emotional,
but there was enough time --
I'll just say this.
Shannon does
some high-pants dancing.
That means everything.
-He's coming on.
Let's see if we can get him
to do a little high-pants
dancing.
It would be fantastic.
But basically all these people
go to this, like, spa,
meditation retreat
type of place,
and you start finding out
each -- more and more details,
like it or not --
about all of the characters.
And it's well done.
-Yeah, it's not
always flattering.
It's like, everybody's kind of
a mess in their own way.
And then they all just start
kind of, like,
clashing together, and it's fun,
it's wild, it's trippy.
And also I thought it was
kind of nice that,
at such a weird time,
that it was, like,
strangers helping people,
which is -- to me, it was
a nice, like, reaffirming thing
that in this crazy time,
I'm like, "Yeah, sometimes,
like, even strangers
are going to be the ones
to help you."
-Yeah, I agree.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Melissa McCarthy
in "Nine Perfect Strangers."
Take a look.
-Meet my beautiful,
beautiful girls.
Wife Heather, daughter Zoe.
-Hi.
-Pleasure to meet you.
-Likewise.
So, what brings you here?
'Cause I have to say
you look pretty perfect.
-Why would you say something
like that?
-I meant it as a compliment.
I'm sorry.
-I think we're gonna explore
the hot springs,
maybe get a quick soak,
do a few laps in the pool,
maybe even visit the sacred spa.
-Should I show you
the hot spring?
-Please do.
Ciao, Frances.
-Ciao.
-Come on, ladies.
Jump-start on bliss.
-Nice to meet you.
Heather's a bitch.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you lay it in there.
Come on.
Melissa McCarthy, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Nine Perfect Strangers,"
premieres Wednesday on Hulu.